they become the red gold of Nigeria at
many markets such as here in ibadan in
the southwest of the country tomatoes
are in such short supply that they cost
five times as much as just a couple of
weeks ago
that's why radio host IO on A&E no
longer enjoys buying groceries she has
to cook every day for her family of four
and she needs tomatoes for nearly every
dish before I cook stew twice in a week
Monday Tuesday Wednesday it will be
stewed and when while their child a
Friday weekend I cook soup this time
around I cook once me I cook my food it
doesn't cost you I was in a week you
know since I cannot really go for that
price
a tiny month by the name of tuta
absoluta is the comfort behind the loss
of the Nigerians favorite food viola
okay has long been researching the
insect the biologist says that it's so
difficult to control because it's larvae
live inside the plant's leaves making it
hard for farmers to treat them with
insecticide he has to use about three or
four insecticide not together not as a
cocktail but rotationally the first week
he can use insecticide a and the second
wait insecticide B and third week
insects si si you know and then start
rotating and even then many larvae still
survive in the leaves in some regions of
Nigeria they've destroyed nearly all of
the tomato plants that's why oke is
experimenting with other very simple
measures in her research greenhouse a
trap made up of a bowl of water with
some detergent the light is meant to
attract the nocturnal monks Nigeria's
researchers have reacted quickly but the
more they understand about the pest the
more obvious it becomes that there's no
quick fix
in the meantime Nigerians have found
their own ways to deal with the tomato
crisis on the other side of ebay
market barred more vegetable peddlers
have been filling their shelves with
tomato paste and canned tomatoes the
Nigerian city has begun to strictly
regulate the import of these products
that's why some vendors have been simply
bringing them in from across the border
in neighboring Benin by night according
to the shoppers here it's the only way
to accommodate the fast-growing demand
radio host a lion day meanwhile has
found another solution for her tomato
problem she's been experimenting with
new recipes without the staple
ingredient I used to slice to metal
inside that fried egg I'll slice a lot
of to me today it's not that it is too
costly in the market so I used onions it
just likes plenty on the inside it's
then I'm okay
bell peppers carrots eggplants the
region offers many fresh vegetables
according to a Leon day and they're
great for cooking with but as soon as
prices drop again she'll buy a large
bucket of fresh tomatoes for her family